all right everybody welcome to another
YouTube hangout I'm super excited to be
back with you guys today I have a
special guest a new friend cloris Kylie
and we are talking today about how to
connect with influential people so that
you can kind of leverage their influence
leverage their audience and their
expertise to get your message your
product or services out there and I'm
gonna have some questions and you guys
can ask the questions to pick her brain
for the next a little bit cloris welcome
aboard well thank you having such an
honor to have you doing here today so
for the people watching who may not be
familiar with what you're all about yet
I mean is that quick and chill but you
want to give a little bit more context
so they know a little more about what
you're doing yeah sure what I do I work
with coaches authors consultants
speakers trainers anybody who is
profiting from their expertise to share
that message and to reach the right
clients because it's not just about
reaching anyone right it's about
connecting with the people who number
one can appreciate what you do and your
value and number two can afford your
services of course because you have a
business you have to stay in business
and number three is to apply what you
teach again you want people who are
ready to take action and that's why I
helped so one of the things that I did
when I was in that first business that I
was super pumped about that helped was I
mean I called him a guide to
professional success and I connected
with a whole bunch of other famous
authors you know Tony Robbins and Zig
Ziglar and all these guys and got an
article there and then also added my own
article to this guy to kind of lifted my
brand because I'm associated with these
guys well I mean that really helped me
in building my brand in like very early
days what are some of the ways that you
recommend or what's one of the first
somebody hasn't that any work with
influential people no influencer
marketing where should they start what
do you recommend yes that's definitely
something that I've done ever and to
build my own brand in my own business
and I want you to think as connecting
with them
people not just us as something that
will help your brand but something that
will help your belief in what is
possible for you because what happens is
once you connect with people who have
achieved great things then you start to
see yourself as as somebody who could
potentially get there see like you see
the possibilities and that's really the
only way to achieve something great is
when you see yourself you can visualize
yourself achieving something wonderful
and so I really want you to consider
that like its power you know once you
start to connect with people who have
influence then you start to become an
influential person yourself and I would
say the first thing you have to do is to
select somebody who you can clearly
resonate with somebody who shares your
values and who you admire you would want
to be like right you always wanted the
people you would want to be like so just
find that person and they'll really
become their advocate they of course the
easiest thing to do is to follow them on
social media and to support them that
way now it's easy to think okay well if
I just kind of automate retweeting their
stuff or if I can just kind of like
their post is that going to be enough
it's not you really have to go above and
beyond so when you retweet something at
a comment that creates value for their
audience when you go to their blog and
you're going to post up a comment there
really say something that shows how you
know your stuff how you have something
to contribute on Facebook same story you
want to be one of those comments on
Facebook that people click like on the
comment that's what you want to be to
really stand out and slowly but surely
that influencer will notice you and I
actually did that with this woman called
I see her name is Melanie Todaro and she
is pretty big on social medias he has a
huge following and I just love her
content so I started by first asking her
actually first of doing everything she
posed she put out any posts I would
comment I would retweet it share it and
then once she had like that knowledge
about you know who I was I invited her
to connect on LinkedIn so it's important
that you use LinkedIn
for that purpose but it's not just say
hey connect it's just about writing a
customized message that shows number one
why you think I hope you admire this
person and number two what you will be
able to to give or to contribute to that
person because remember it's a two-way
street when you have to find a way that
you can help this person so that's what
I did I invited her to connect on
LinkedIn as she said yes and then after
that I was able to support her even more
so I would you know really post on her
LinkedIn comments I would recommend I
recommended her on LinkedIn and people
love to have that a recommendation on
their LinkedIn profile so I went really
above and beyond so Melanie a new me so
then by the time I waited up a while
right you have to build a relationship
and when I was time for four there was
the right time I said hey would you like
to be on my show because I have an
online radio show and she didn't
hesitate like yes of course
and later on during the interview she
told me Clarissa I don't give interviews
anymore I just don't have time and I
said yes to you because I know you know
how good you have been and how much you
share my stuff and I feel like I owe you
so I'm here today so that's that's an
example of what you can do I love it and
it's so true and I think too many people
give up too soon you know the people who
are commenting on all my videos and are
on a lot of the live streams and the
live chat it doesn't take a long time to
necessarily have to make an impact if
you are consistent with it so you know
if you guys watching a live chat you see
Zeno and Xena's got this little toolbar
next to him he's been made a moderator
of the chat because he's been in on all
of the chats and he's always sharing
love and he's always had an impact some
of the other people who popping on one
shot you know I'm not gonna remember you
the next time and it's not that I'm you
know I'm not trying to remember you just
there's so many people were watching
every video that it can be hard and so a
lot of people like to come in for one
video they leave a chat comments and all
that was a really good comment he didn't
recognize me you didn't see it you know
understanding the people you're trying
to connect with if they have a big
following they may not see your one
golden
comment so it has to be consistent right
it's like everything they put out you
want to be leaving a really golden piece
of comment around to help them out and
with time people do recognize it I think
people just quit a little too soon you
have to be persistent just like anything
if you want to make anything happen just
have to keep at it and you'll eventually
be successful so so you know somebody
who say me so I'm like I'm trying I have
my book right I'm promoting my book so
yes hey like that could be really
helpful for me to go and connect with
people who could potentially market my
book what do you recommend for me is it
just making a list of people who you
know have audiences that I think would
be relevant that I have a message that
connects with them and then following
them on social sharing you know their
content trying to make an impact and
then approach them about the book well
how would you how would you dissect what
I should do to throw my but definitely
yeah I would say the making the list is
important I actually have a list of the
I have it right here on my bulletin
board it's a it's a list of my top 50 so
the top 50 are those people I really
want to support on a continuous basis
and every morning I look at the list and
say hey who have I have I supported this
week who I haven't and then I actually
go and check their stuff I go to the
Twitter pages Facebook Linkedin see what
else they have out and try to support
them as much as possible and so stable
you know you have your list you have
your target and yes it has to be people
who have an audience that is similar to
yours so you can sell your book of
course and and then you start connecting
with people and keep in mind a song
let's say that your book is coming out
in four weeks then it might not be
enough time for you to create a
relationship though it's something you
have to strategize and start right now I
mean today after this show you
definitely have to start your list and
start those relationships and the more
time that goes by you know the sooner
you will see who is being responsive and
who is not because you have some people
will ignore you and that's just part of
the game right so
you say okay well move on right to the
next person and then you have that that
circle of people who you feel that yes
they respond to you they resonate with
you and then you can go and and reach
out and contact them and I was thinking
if you really want to take it above and
beyond then you could do something that
really puts the name out there to
increase their influence and and their
reach and so I'll give you a quick
example I love this show is it's not
live anymore but they had two seasons
it's called fat guys in the woods on the
Weather Channel's now if you ever
watched it I love the shows weird I just
love survival stuff and there were these
three guys who needed a change in their
life and survival expert Craig Stewart
took them out into the woods for a week
but no no water no food they had to
survive so loved the show so that you
know I said this show you know to be in
the show you have to have the same
qualities that you have to be an
entrepreneur and so I went ahead and I
wrote an article lessons for
entrepreneurs from fat guys in the woods
and wrote the article I was inspired and
then I they will share the article with
creeks with the hosts and believe it or
not he saw the tweet it was just a tweet
he clicked on the article and read it
and he loved the article and what did he
do he share that article with his
audience so I had all these people and
took who are into survival go into my
site and check it out my stuff but but
the key is like see how I did something
that was like above and beyond so in
your case if you want to promote your
book and you have this list of people
and what could you do maybe you could
you know case them in your own show
which has a huge following and that's
what I do with my own online radio show
I've had best-selling authors and
entrepreneurs who are making millions of
dollars so you know I give them more of
an expanded reach by being on my show so
you have to leverage what you have maybe
you have a blog so go ahead and you have
them guest post on your blog or if they
don't have time then you write the
article and mention them and their
lessons that you have gained from them
so whatever platform that you have
whether it be a youtube show a radio
show a blog use it use it to support
these influencers and they will
appreciate it and then that's when you
you know they'll want to reciprocate and
help you promote your book I gotta get
hustlin I gotta I gotta start now Cloris
is lighting the fire under me here I
gotta get I gotta get busy
one of the other things that I found
super helpful is when targeting people
on social media to make sure that
they're active in responding to comments
on that platform and so like Twitter
super easy you can see their tweets and
replies if somebody's just broadcasting
and they never apply to anybody they're
probably not even paying attention there
and so you tweeting them every day is
probably not gonna have an impact
you know youtubers and they were
applying to every comment or at least
are they looking in the comments or
they're just if they're just
broadcasting then you can be spending a
lot of time doing the wrong thing where
you want to look where they're actually
engaged and most people are in all the
platforms but they'll have one that they
actually use themselves and it's not
their team so this snapchat or Instagram
or Facebook or whatever it is and then
that's that's when you want to be on
because you want to get their attention
as much as possible not their assistant
or somebody on their team what are your
thoughts there completely I agree
because I want you to think about your
influencers as an audience right just
like when you want to build your
business right don't you want to know
your avatar to really know what your
avatar hangs out their problems be and
behaviors and their their needs and
wants and their aspirations same thing
happens with the influencers that you're
targeting its your audience it's a
special audience right it's really small
you want to really kind of pinpoint the
people who can help you the most
so that's yes you have to study them
really learn as much about them as
possible and if you really want to go
way above and beyond you know why don't
you sign up for the programs right if
they have for example if they have a
training program on how to how to get
more sales you sign up and become a you
know one of those people who
participates and gives feedback and
actually gives a testimony
after product and that's when they will
really remember you and if something
comes to mind to I belong to this
program called joint venture insider
circle in which you connect with with
people who have similar audiences and
and so forth and the person who created
this program she said when she was
starting out which is now is like a you
know they make seven figures with a
program but when she was starting out
she took this Lisa Sasha Buchert
who calls herself the queen of sales
conversion and she has all this problems
well how to sell your problems and
services so she loved the program she
actually created a video testimonial of
how much she loved it and guess what
Lisa I noticed her and she noticed her
and she actually wanted to thank her
personally for the video so those are
things that you can go to really go a
pala beyond one of the things I did to
get on somebody's radar I've got a
couple times for youtubers I would go to
see who is leaving comments on their
YouTube channel I connect with the most
common commenters on that person's
channel and I would send them a message
saying hey I love this youtuber just
like you do I want to thank them for all
the work that they're doing and I strung
together like 50 of these people who
made a one-minute video or 30-second
video to say thank you so much for all
the work and the love and to get those
50 you have to reach out to like 500 of
them but then I make this video of just
all of their top fans thinking them and
of course I have my own message in there
too and it's it's pretty impossible to
not pay attention your your point of
going way above and beyond this is just
so far crazy above and beyond that
nobody does that you're at least you
have an introduction now you still need
to hit them with value they self to see
you know importance in what you're doing
maybe they hate my book you know who
knows but at least you have the in
because you did all that work to really
stand up for them I love that even
that's that's really way above and
beyond and you probably saw amazing
results from that and you know the thing
is once you connect with that person who
a lot of influence then it becomes much
easier right like you know I'm sure that
the first person you connected with and
you can say to somebody else hey you
know you want to be on my show I
interviewed such-and-such and then it
becomes much easier to connect with
influential people sure and also asking
what they what they want you know like I
was on Lewis with Lewis house if you
know Lewis house he's has a school of
greatness podcast I just just ask him
hey who's like a dream person you want
to have on your podcast and he gave me
four or five names of people that he
would love to have on his show and so
it's now it's on my radar like if I can
give him an introduction somehow some
way I don't guarantee but if you know
what those people want that you're
connecting with then you become way more
important to them as well oh yeah it's
about providing value always and
something something else you can do to
provide value if let's say that you
don't have the right connections right
you're like okay I'm starting out how I
don't know anybody how can I introduce
them to anyone well why don't you send
them your ideas I mean your ideas are
valuable and if you have a way if you
think of a way that they could be
improving what they do even more or some
creative way that they could even expand
that reach even more just send it to
them you know that's that's what James
Altucher does you know he's he loves
ideas he sends ideas to all these
companies and some of them really
appreciated he had Amazon fly him just
because he sent a huge document of his
ideas to Amazon and they had in my
headquarters you know they came because
they loved what he had to say so again
if you are able to provide value and you
can because you have your mind and your
your creativeness and your passion then
yes so if you if it's valuable they will
notice you mm-hmm yeah I think if you
can figure out any of their goals you
know I you know I want to interview
Howard Schultz he's the CEO of Starbucks
I want to have him on my show right
maybe you don't know Starbucks you know
maybe you don't know Howard Schultz he's
not really on Twitter you know it's a
private guy so it's hard to get access
to but like if you were doing so say he
was on Twitter you know if you were
tweeting him every day seeing Howard I'd
love to have you on up and show how you
gotta get out of and show how it's like
please be on Evans show right like
even if he never came on I appreciate
your hustle right like I'm gonna notice
you I say dude thank you so much for
your love what's your business about and
I want to click on your profile and see
what's in your Twitter bio and click on
your website and maybe there's some kind
of thing right so even if you don't have
that connection just the work just the
hustle just the energy that you're
pointing to try to help is loved and
that often gets recognized I would
recognize that I want to turn to the
live chat because I got some questions
going on here and I want to respect that
- Savita is asking how do you deal with
failure so you know you reach out these
people you really want to get their
attention a lot of times you may not get
it how do you deal with that failure of
rejection there yes it's a good question
and I think well first of all you have
to ask yourself have I tried this long
enough and long enough he'll know and it
has been too long I would say a minimum
that you you should try to support it a
person would be you know three to six
months to really do as much as you can
to support them if you if you really
have no response whatsoever then it's
just a matter of saying well you know
for some reason this wasn't the person
for me and that's fine to just think
that somehow you're being guided to the
right person for you you don't want it's
just like if you had you try to get
together with your friend and she was
always canceling on you after a while
you would get the hint that this is not
the right friend for you you know there
are so many people out there who can
provide the same value and connection so
it's time to move on to the next person
and that's why it's important that you
start with a big enough less though that
you can just kind of support all these
people and then then eventually narrow
it down to those people who you really
want to be connected with yeah I think
as long as you have the passion for it
as long as you still feel like like if
somebody says no where somebody is just
ignoring you maybe you lose interest in
them maybe you know you're not as
exciting anymore and that's the time to
move on if you really feel like you know
whoever's on your 50 list cloris like I
really want to get those people and for
me I
keep going like until I lose the passion
for that having that guest I'll just
keep going until until I get an answer
until they get a yes or I know and just
make it part of your daily daily ritual
and I don't see it as that like you know
if you tweet out PewDiePie is and
respond to you on the first day or you
know you tweet out the president and he
doesn't reply to you it's just a step
right like you're running a marathon and
you took one step there is a finish line
and it's it it could only be failure if
you stop like if you just give up on
this whole influencer marketing thing
I'm not gonna connect with any
influential people anymore because it
doesn't work you know that's failure
where if you keep taking steps every day
it's just understanding there is a
finish line you're gonna get there you
just took one more step today and then
you need another step tomorrow and the
list of tomorrow it's just another step
and each step is a no or like a
non-response and eventually you go and
you get you get your yes shifting that
perspective we think might help I think
so yeah plus you can learn you know from
those knows you know maybe what can I do
differently this time with this new
person with the same person and kind of
tweak your strategy because you know
your failures are lessons they're pay
for lessons but they are lessons so
Sherry's writing in same LinkedIn is her
number one site for social media is
there a preference that you have on how
you're reaching out what you're doing
well sherry I think it depends on how
active the person is on LinkedIn or any
other social media platform I personally
love LinkedIn because that way I can
connect with a person I can support them
on other posts I can recommend them I
can send them an email if I want to have
them on my show so I feel like people
who are active on Linkedin they check
their LinkedIn emails so I think it's a
good platform but then you have to
figure out how acts how active they are
so can it depends just like the whole
thing about the audience you know where
do they hang out and then go to where
that person is and really reach out to
them but I'd personally liked like
LinkedIn interesting I do almost nothing
on LinkedIn but I think
thing yeah I mean I agree hundred
percent - it's where the audience where
they're at where they actually are you
want to you want to play to that if
doing multiple places and play to your
strengths my default for reaching out I
wish YouTube had a great way to reach
out to people they don't like the you
leave a message it gets sent to spam in
otherwise there's an email that you can
write an email isn't as great my usual
go-to if they're in a different place
it'll be Twitter okay because I have a
following there too I have two hundred
thousand whatever followers on Twitter
so it usually triggers the alerts or
whatever it's not some no-name like
brand new Twitter account person writing
so it allows me to get in a little bit
and I built my Twitter following with
partly with that intention is that hey
if I if I call out to somebody they'll
pay attention if I if I'm upset at the
company for bad customer service they're
gonna pay attention but yeah most
important is where they are like if
they're all over LinkedIn LinkedIn and
figure it out and be active and share
their posts and comments and being their
groups and you know they you should be a
known quantity right to close this point
they should know who you are they should
know your name exactly something I was
going to say actually if the person who
you're trying to connect with wrote a
book that's actually great because first
of all you can write a review of read
their book of course and then write a
review on Amazon and just tell them you
know tweet them hey I just posted this
review on Amazon what I've done I've
posted the link to to you know the book
and then a picture of me holding the
book and saying this this book is
amazing and I put it on Twitter and
tweet that and it gets their attention
so you know books are awesome because
they want to sell their books and they
love to get reviews on them positive
reviews for so you know that's another
great way to connect with them yeah and
I would say to add on to that point and
your art into it whatever you're good at
talent to that bring that creativity to
it so for me it's making videos there's
a couple of authors whose books I'm
supporting and the way I do it is we'll
make a video about it I'll read a
passage
and then we'll edit it together and have
motivational music and it becomes this
promotional vehicle for them that when
they see that Wow
let you really turn my words into
something amazing
I've seen other people who are singers
sing a book review right or if you're
you know if you're a programmer you make
you make a little program around the
book or something like something unique
different it's something that you're
really good at what's your art what do
you you know what do you love to create
create around the book so that like
nobody's song a book review for that
person before you know this lots of
singers nobody's gonna take that so the
Cloris is point about like extra step
right not just the same thing everybody
else is doing they're like wow that
person's saying a book review you know
or compose the song around something in
my book it's like man that's really
that's really wild that's crazy
love that cool dee Wilson is writing in
will this work to break into the music
business well interesting question Dee
what I would say like who are you really
trying to target I would just say that
you wanted to target Rihanna or
something and you know it's pretty
difficult to reach her I would try to
visualize some sort of like staircase to
reach her and then kind of go step by
step so I would say start with somebody
who's a little bit more approachable who
can actually notice your stuff and then
once you're there and you you know that
person then you can go a little bit
higher and so forth I would say having
your own platform really helps so if you
are in the music business you definitely
you know if you have a YouTube channel
you could have a way to have guests on
your channel and perform your music then
you can have that person you've
connected with as you know to interview
them and know about their career in
music and then you've started to create
that following it wants to create that
following and it's a big enough
following that you'll be able to connect
with more and more influential people
until you get to Rihanna you know the
sass that's what I would suggest instead
of kind of shooting for the people who
really have no time to interact with
with anyone
then just just go like step by step
going up that ladder until you reach it
at the top yeah and like again to the
previous I think it works in any
industry so to the previous point where
are they
you know Rihanna has music videos but I
doubt that she's looking through the
comments to say hey this person
commented a lot you know she's probably
on Instagram so that's where you want to
be and maybe what you do is you know
maybe on her birthday you sing her I'll
give you a singer go sing her a happy
birthday and your style or if you're I
don't know what you're doing in the
music industry if you're if you're you
make beats like make her birthday D
something so that like if she happens to
be attention to it
like you have to be good to write you
want to work with Rihanna
she's just if there's a quality
threshold you know you could get on her
radar but if you're if your stuff sucks
she's not gonna do anything with you
right like people can get on my radar
but if I don't like your product or
service I'm not gonna promote it so your
stuff has to be good and something that
when she listens to it she's gonna be
like and that's who is this person who
wrote this thing and this is this is
quality and yes I like the point of like
you can have Rihanna as your goal but
then like what's the path to Rihanna who
are the other people you need to get to
and the music industry is all about
collaborations mmm right like how many
albums are produced where there's
somebody else on the track with them
they're always looking for either those
sharing audiences or just a different
vibe you know one song has a different
feel to it a special guest on it and
some artists are much more open to that
than others - you know like youtubers -
right I do a lot of these kind of
hangouts right I do a lot of
collaborations we do it every week so
with if Cloris writes and we make this
up you know it's it's it's easy for me
to say yes because I do this a lot if I
never have guests on and I'm always just
doing my own thing it's gonna be a lot
harder to get me to do an interview
right and so understanding like if
there's an artist who does tons of
collabs and you have this sick beat or a
special way of rapping or you just
acapella like crazy whatever it is even
they'll use your little chunk in their
next song so - course is point about
having like the list targets that list
right to the right people who could be
good fits for you correct yeah you
really have to know them though to have
to really know that person as you said
know if they do cooperations or not and
that's when you know you have a chance I
love it
have you seen examples and like you're
typically working with thought leaders
experts right business kind of people
right yeah exactly so uh I would say
I've seen examples of people who connect
with with those get the top leaders in
the industry just by doing what I what I
said and just participating in in their
programs and courses really gives you
that edge so if you are in another
industry then ask yourself you know how
could I be a crack how could I stand out
and meet up part of the small I guess a
group of people that they pay more
attention to some of these people have
mastermind groups and there would be a
investment but if you join them
they're definitely connecting with them
so I wasn't the entrepreneur on fire
they've podcast with Johnny two months
and the way I initially reached out to
John it was just again I just followed
him before I was listening to this show
I said why I love the show and what I
believed in and he actually said you're
a great guest for my show so I didn't
have to do too much but now because I'm
connected with him a lot of many doors
like have opened for me you know all
these people want to have me on their
podcast so again it's awesome so it's a
matter of of connecting with that one
person that opens the door for you to
many other opportunities right and you
know we've been talking about online it
may also be off low like maybe the
people that you're connecting what I
connect with they're not on social we're
doing a top ten video and Tyree skips in
the actor and for him he wanted to
connect with this director is what is
his favorite director he wanted to
connect with and the director is not on
social media so he can't tweet him I
send my video or anything but he knew
this director was gonna be at this party
it's like I'm gonna go to the party I
don't care about party I don't care
about anybody else there I'm not there
to get drunk or me to the P I want to
meet the director I'm gonna have a
conversation with that director
and then I'm gonna go home you know and
you had that conversation then using
that time to stand up so you know to
your point about like maybe they have a
mastermind group or maybe they're going
to do a book signing somewhere you know
maybe they have some local events or
some tour thing that you can go and
shake their hand and introduce yourself
just getting on their ass something yeah
that's right yeah cool
Cloris it's crazy how quickly half an
hour flies by for people who are curious
about you what you're up to reaching out
I know you have your website
Cloris Kylee calm we're linked it up in
the description you have an ebook what's
what's the best kind of next step for
people who want to learn about what
you're up to
well yeah that's thank you ever know
that can definitely go to my site is
Cloris Kylee calm and there you'll be
able to download my ebook which has
eight proven ways to build authority to
grow your audience and connect with the
right clients there's a quiz it's a fun
quiz to see your client attraction style
if you are in the expert type business
and service based business I have a
social media template all kinds of stuff
like free resources for you to access so
I think that's like the central hub that
you can go to chorus Kylie calm I love
it what course thank you for taking the
time with us today thank you guys all
for watching live continue to believe or
whatever if you're one where it is I
will see you soon thank you